to say i want to keep you up i have a
question for you
yeah um obviously we missed you very
much while you were gone
and you asked annie and esther to
the show did you miss us
did it give you fomo that you weren't
here in the room did you like that
episode
when i started bad friends right there
was it it
i started it with a sense of kind of a
guilt why
i'll tell you why and i'm just telling
you my honest answer and i'm not okay
it's because
tiger belly for me is um
it and i this made me true may not be
but i think it's more
toward the honest side um saved me
in many ways okay not only did it save
my career but i think it saved us two as
a couple
you know it gives us something to do
together a project you know
um there's a lot of trust that goes into
something like this and um
you know we've had our blowouts and
we've had our you know our heads
have budded but you know at the end of
the day it's our little baby
and it's our you know it's it's
literally like you know
a part of us it's our family member
tiger belly
and um when i started with bad friends i
felt like i was abandoning it a little
bit you know i mean because it's like
you know but you know i think i did bad
friends
because of all of us you know i think in
many ways i don't want to get into the
financial
situation but in many ways you know um
i did bad friends for us okay
i also but let me finish yeah but there
was a side of me that was like
thought how great would it be if
you know kalila could start something up
with a couple of girls and i've always
thought because of
guys we [ __ ] and and i also obviously
i'm friends with
a lot of female podcasters i love what
they're doing
so it's like um i thought i think it
would be good
at first in my head i was like how great
would it be you know
if it was like an all-female asian
podcast that you did
but then later you know i thought you
know it just two
really funny people so i think you annie
and um esther um
filling in for me you know i mean on
tiger belly number one
was great i don't have to see because i
don't listen to any of them
so but i just already know in my heart i
never asked
how did it go or anything like that i
just like i just know it's going to be
good
right because it's those two right and
i'm excited to announce
wait we're not announcing anything
what are you what are you saying i just
wanted your input on what you thought
i thought we're making an announcement
we're not all right so here's
here's what can i just say what my dream
is then yeah my dream is
is that you annie and esther right
would do a podcast together is my dream
for you i think those are the two
perfect esther's
[ __ ] up she's a [ __ ] up danny is
going to be so happy you
said that because i saw her earlier
right i saw her earlier today right
and at the my first reaction when i see
her i'm like what the [ __ ] is that
you know what i mean she's [ __ ] up
okay
annie is just garbage she's human
garbage with you know
walking around just the floppiness of
her you know what i mean
there's just something just you know i
mean like she sweats
nicotine juice or something you know man
she just has that vibe and i looked at
you three
earlier today and i went that's it
i love it they're both very talented
young ladies and
not young but when you first started bad
friends i was really excited
i i never want to ever like feel like
you you have we have our own thing
but i feel like you shine
very differently across different people
like that's just how life is like you
are so funny with santino and i
completely completely
i think that in one of the earlier
episodes of tiger belly too i was like
wait a second like you guys
would be perfect to do this together and
then eric griffin was like why would you
say something
like that remember but it's the same way
like i feel with annie and esther it's
like if we were to ever do a podcast
together
you would be getting a completely
different side of me because who i am
um with you is not who i am with them
and i do tend to
open up more in like a girly way with
them
yeah where i wouldn't you know i'm for
some reason i say way more [ __ ] up
things with them
yeah it's like with andrew i'm more i
here i would cave
into my you know my my faults right
like at the end of the day i go all
right yeah that was me i bad or my bad
or you know
i should have done this you're right you
know i try to like you know learn from
my you know behaviors
with andrew i think i i would stand firm
and not cave in as much you know i mean
because i just
[ __ ] i hate him sometimes i just
you know when i look at him i just go
god there's everything about you
irritates me right so i think that you
know
you know um i wish we would have used um
the bad friends instead of calling it
bad friends riffing without griffin
we almost named bad friends riffen
without griffin
right and when andrew brought that up i
chuckled on the phone
so hard and i go but then i realized
if we put that out there it would be it
would have been
irreparable damage devastating for eric
right but how funny would that be very
funny
yeah yeah um that's like if me esther
and annie started a podcast
called having a time without rick
[Laughter]
that's really funny and he's gonna clip
this you should have that
you should name it that if you do one
with those girls
and we promise with more than 50 years
as a family owned business
we've got you covered
yeah yeah you know shout out rick yeah
rick is kidding
rick is an interesting guy but here
there's another guy that's uh you know
in the podcast world has really kind of
taken a hold of his you know vibe and
i love what he does i love he works so
hard
that pod that's not even a podcast
that's a show it's a show
yeah he really does fine-tune it to make
it and make it feel
it's it's a perfect show yeah he's great
yeah and also i just love he's a lovely
guy
you know wouldn't want to go camping
with him you know or like just
long distance anything with him you know
on vacation
but from afar i'm a big fan of his you
know um
i'd like to do that with you guys post
vaccine please if we could all just jump
in an rv
together and drive around america
first location um i would my first stop
i would like to
i've never been to yosemite
i've also never been to the grand canyon
you guys
i've been to yosemite let's do it have
you been
have you been to the grand canyon